Usually we think the brain is in charge, not
the heart, but in Soviet Russia, heartbeat
controls YOU.
Actually.
That's misleading… your heartbeat can control
you all the time, regardless of your sociopolitical
system or country of origin.
Hey heart-beaters, Trace here for Dnews.
You probably know that the way you feel can
affect your heart rate.
If you’re feelin’ calm, your heart rate’s
nice and slow, chances are you don’t even
feel it.
And when faced with fear or… something really
exciting, you might feel your heart pounding
away in your chest.
But your heart rate doesn't just respond to
what you're feeling, it can -in some ways-
control how you feel by changing the way you
process incoming information.
A study lead by Dr. Sarah Garfinkel and published
in 2016 in the Journal Trends in Cognitive
Sciences found cardiovascular arousal, or
that state where your heart is pumping faster
or harder than normal, can actually intensify
your feelings of fear and anxiety.
The researchers say this happens because every
heartbeat- the strength, the timing- is signaled
to the brain thanks to receptors in the blood
vessels called baroreceptors.
When the heart rate and blood pressure increase,
baroreceptors tell this to the brain, and
it’s thought that the brain can interpret
that signal as fear.
In a set of studies by Garfinkel, participants
were shown images of faces -- some that looked
neutral, and some that looked scary.
Researchers timed the images so that some
would coincide with when participants hearts
were contracting and pumping blood -- the
systole phase -- and others would coincide
with when the heart was relaxing, or in the
diastole phase.
Turns out the participants could spot the
scary images faster when the heart was contracting
than when it was relaxing.
The same effect was not seen with the neutral
images.
In fact, the neutral images were perceived
slightly more at the diastole phase.
And in another study published in the Journal
of Neuroscience, Swiss researchers found that
when the participants were shown a flashing
object that was in sync with their heartrate,
it took them longer to even notice it compared
to when it was not in sync.
It was as though the heart rate cancelled
out some of the incoming information.
There is also some evidence showing that heart
rate may impact the way we perceive time.
Researchers out of the Japan Society of Kansei
Engineering tested this theory on 48 people
with the help of a little music.
They varied the tempo of the music and by
putting the study participants on exercise
bikes, they could speed up or slow down their
heart rates.
The authors found that with a slight increase
in heartrate, people underestimated how long
the music was.
With a really fast heart rate they overestimated
the duration, thinking the music lasted longer
than it really did.
And still another study published in the journal
Biological Psychology found that people who
are more sensitive or aware of their own heartbeat
are better at judging duration of time.
I feel like that's totally me.
The thing is, it's not a superpower.
A study published by Chemnitz University of
Technology in Germany found that heart rate
alone may not actually be to blame when you
feel like time is dragging by.
They showed subjects a presentation while
they were either exercising or holding their
breaths.
Exercising would increase their heart rate,
while breath-holding would actually slow it
down.
Participants were then asked to rate how intense
they thought the strain of the activity was
and how long they thought it took.
The results showed that intense strain -- or
what the researchers called arousal -- led
to higher time estimates than just faster
heart rate.
We like to think of ourselves as higher animals,
with the brain driving the body; completely
rational and independent of our ancient programming,
but studies like these show our biology is
affecting our perception of time, our decision-making
and how we look at the world around us!
We're just big dumb animals after all.
Sorry, my heartbeat was really high on that
one, forgive me.
This isn't the first story we've done about
how your body controls you!
The heart isn't alone in this!
Amy has a video about how our gut instincts
might actually be real, here . Can you feel
your heartbeat?
Do you have a burning science question?
Ask us in the comments and subscribe so you
can be sure and get the answer!
Thanks for watching DNews.